aaron nola makes a start for the
philadelphia philly 7-6 with a 449 era
the 28 year old right-hander all right
so here's trey turner to lead things off
he's very familiar with this ballpark
and with this pitcher as well
dollar with a wind-up and again the 0-2
pitch to turner swinging a miss he got
him
curveball and there's a strikeout to
begin the ball game
for arinola against trey turner here's
max munsey hitting 275 with 22 home runs
64 runs batted in
and the 3-2 again swinging a miss got
him curveball
back-to-back strikeouts to start the
ball game will smith's had a solid
second half he's got 15 home runs at 51
rbis
he has 19 runs batted in since the
all-star break nolda kicks in the pitch
swinging at miss got him with the
curveball and
what a start tonight for nova
one two three go the dodgers three
strikeouts for nola to begin the ball
game and we'll head for the bottom of
the first max scherzer
new uni headed to the mound matchers are
on the mound for the dodgers nine and
four with the 275 era 37 year old right
hander making his 21st start of this
season when we talk about a couple mvp
candidates potentially for the dodgers
here's one of them for the phillies and
bryce harper who is third in the league
in ops seventh in the league in average
and
he's gotten better and better as this
year has gone on
scherzer's 3-2 to hyper
called strike three at the knees
scherzer took something off it
arguing but that was a strike yeah it
was right at the kneecaps he strikes out
looking first strikeout of the night for
scherzer and the side retired into the
first on to the second when we come back
it's the dodgers nothing philly's
nothing aj pollock he was four for ten
in the angel series
he kicks and deals in the pitch breaking
ball swinging a miss he got another one
with a curveball
that's the fourth strikeout for nola
five batters into the ball game
that'll bring chris taller up taylor
an all-star this year
2-1 pitch on the way swinging a hot shot
to third torres has it spins fires to
second one onto first double play
that was spectacular
ronald torreira starts the 5-4-3 double
play
my oh my what a play
dodgers are done in their half of the
second no runs a hit
and nobody left will go to the bottom of
the second no score
and ronald teres
comes to the plate
gregorius leading at first two men out
one ball two strike pitch
swung on a missed strike three
he finally got to reyes
and scherzer
heads back to the dugout
after two innings in philadelphia it's
the dodgers nothing philly's nothing
cody ballinger will lead off for the
dodgers no score here in the third
nolda kicks and deals the pitch swinging
to miss
fastball got him well at least he cut
down with two strikes oh wait no he
didn't
man
that is uh strikeout number five for
nola his first
strikeout that ended with a fastball the
others were all on
curveballs and now billy mckinney 2-2
pitch on the way swing and a miss he got
another one and another curveball
and billy mckinney
goes down on strikes that six of the
first eight batters have struck out
tonight against aaron nolda that'll
bring max scherzer the pitcher
up to the plate one ball two strikes
here's the wind up and the pitch swing
at a miss he got him
and erin nola has struck out seven of
the first nine dodgers that he has faced
here tonight we're going to the bottom
of the third inning at citizens bank
park fills nothing and the dodgers
nothing max scherzer will face the
center fielder travis jankowski
got him with a cutter for his third k
cutter speed the slider movement that
thing moved the mile
one gone in the third for the pitcher
nola
gets him looking with the fastball back
to back caves to open this inning
herrera flied to mckinney in right field
in the first inning hole for one tonight
payoff pitch swung on and missed strike
three scherzer strikes out the side he's
got five in the game
three innings done in philadelphia we go
to the fourth dodgers nothing philly's
nothing one out for max muncie
once he went down swinging in the first
here's the 2-2 pitch swinging the ground
ball right side diving miller he's got
it
gets up flips under hand and nalda and
brad miller not known for the glove but
makes a fine play laying out for that
one at first base 3-1 the put out
lead-off man on and here's harper for
count full his first time took strike
three in a backdoor cutter lead off man
aboard in the fourth an o2 from scherzer
to harper
got him with a change up
strikeout number six for sure azure he's
gotten harper both times and this change
up goes straight down it starts in the
middle of the plate and stays in the
middle so it gets the swing but then the
action going straight down gets the
strikeout and they're gonna put the tarp
on the fields
alfonso marquez is saying let's get
everybody off jt rio mutto is the hitter
with a one and two count yes he is
pitched now to rio muto
swung on and foul tipped into the glove
of will smith for the strikeout
so two men out and that'll turn out to
be strikeout number seven for scherzer
seeger is the only dodger with a hit
lifts the fly ball the other way deep
left center field it's gone
opposite field home run corey seeger
and the dodgers break through first
and it's one nothing dodgers corey
seeger with his fifth home run of the
year an opposite field shot sevessia
will step to the plate he is uh oh for
two with two strikeouts in his big
league career both of his at-bats coming
earlier this season
the 2-2
strike three calls got him looking with
a fastball
sides retired dodgers get on the board
the lead-off home run by corey seeger
it's his fifth of the year
two hits in the inning two were left
we'll go to the bottom of the fifth
phillies trail one nothing
one on one out for will smith
that's an opposite field base it for
will smith
turner's head at home here's the throw
from harper not in time
you can count on one hand how many guys
in this world score on that hit trey
turner is one of them and the dodgers
lead two nothing politico for two today
the number one hitter in the national
league since early july both in average
and slugging
sharp ground ball off of segura into
center field
pollock drives in two and the dodgers
take advantage of this opportunity in
the six
three in the bank and they lead it four
nothing
two on two out the hitters brad miller
go for two today
grounds the first pitch that he sees to
muncie at first steps on the bag and
that worked out rather quickly so one
pitch out for bruhl he said that was
easy and he heads over to the dugout and
we will go to the top of the seventh
inning dodgers four philadelphia nothing
and that's gonna bring up corey seeger
with the bases loaded
deros santos delivers in the pits swung
on popped up
out into shadow left center field goes
didi gregorius he's backpedaling he
makes a one-handed catch
and that will do it for the dodgers
no runs two hits a walk
three left
going to the bottom of the seventh it's
the dodgers four the fills nothing damon
jones the pride of twin falls idaho
making his major league debut tonight
the first pitch to aj pollock
high bouncer out to shortstop
and indeed he waits for fires across the
diamond
one out so damon jones
throws one pitch in his major league
debut and gets one out
here's turner two balls two strikes
and the pitch breaking ball popped him
up
on the infield and near the bag at
second dede is calling he'll make the
catch
and the side is retired nice bounce back
game for mauricio yovera
as he gets pujols and turner to put out
the fire
muncie the only spot in the order that
hasn't reached tonight muncie turns on a
ball sends it way up there how far will
it go
second deck homer on max muncie
really launched i mean this is called
back legging it
23rd of the year is one of the longest
ones yet and it's five nothing jankowski
had an infield single in the fifth that
was sandwiched in between two strikeouts
lined in the center bellinger's there
with a sliding catch to end the game
and the dodgers shut the phillies out
here in the first game of the road trip
five to nothing